moin und
herzlich willkommen zu der elz mit luca
ist 38 morgens
sondern entschuldigte
mich hier verschenkt gaming stuhl und
ein interessent schreibt dem verkäufer
moin moin wäre der schule noch zu haben
und ist dieser soweit intakt groß wenn
der verkäufer antwortet darauf hin was
ist intakt die kosten wann wo wie ok
sagt die bringen stuhl und schmeißen
deine presse wirklich gar keine zeit
heute morgen halo ist es möglich polen
zu versenden ich glaub nicht holen ist
ziemlich groß
manchmal stelle ich echt mein leben in
frage hier verkauft jemand eine
neuwertige nintendos switch für 250 euro
und er schreibt in die beschreibung der
in serie kaum genutzt in nintendos pitch
üblichen gebrauchsspuren nichts
besonderes ohne spiele und controller
oder kabel und das ist das foto das wär
ich nach einer runde mario kart dir
verkauft jemand einen strandkorb
beziehungsweise gartenmöbel
beziehungsweise einfach ein
unvollendetes projekt für 30 euro und da
stellt sich jetzt wahrscheinlich ein
strandkorb vor wie man den von sylt
kennt die sonnen dingen oder irgendwie
sonnen teil irgendwie
das wird der verkauft ist das hier
das ist eine mülltonne mit zum bambus
verdeckt darüber hier verkauft jemand
einen pavillon in die beschreibung des
produkts schreibt er allerdings pavian
zu verkaufen im guten zustand ich frage
mich manchmal echt er sich die die auto
also die korrekte
verkauft jemand eine rutsche für einen
dünnen hamster und er schreibt in die
beschreibung des produkts verkauf für
diese rutsche für hamster mein hamster
kämpft mit gewichtsproblemen seit den
feiertagen und passt deshalb nicht mehr
in die rutsche es wird nur die rutsche
verkauft damit mein hamster nicht
täglich an seine mutter hüften erinnert
wird tausche auch gegen einen hamster
hantelbank
und das ist das foto
das weiße kopf
das kranke generell werden auf ebay so
viele hamster verkauft auch hier beim
nächsten fehler da wird diese hamster
verkauft und zwar für 1000 euro weil es
ein schurkische abends da ist und er
beschreibt dazu ich verkaufe meinen
haben es da einen bösewicht ist wie man
auf dem bild unschwer erkennen kann
ja ich frage mich am nächsten die bfl
verkauft jemand eine herrenjacke er
verschreibt sich allerdings bei dem
produktnamen und ein aufmerksamer
ebay-nutzer erinnert ihn daran schreibt
ihm darauf für den guten tag ich wollte
sie kurz auf ihre überschrift aufmerksam
machen da steht herren kacke viele grüße
und er schreibt einfach nur ganz viel
lacht weil dies und bedankt sich muss
auch mal sein
dass vernünftige leute da unterwegs sind
genauso wie hier da schreibt nämlich
jemand hallo ich habe interesse auf ihre
wohnung wir sind zu dritt guten tag
leider ist die wohnung sehr klein und
wir daher nur an einzelne personen
vermietet viel erfolg bei der suche nach
einer geeigneten wohnung mit
freundlichen grüßen ich bin
einzelpersonen suche dringend eine
[Musik]
und nicht lachen die verkauft jemand
einen spider man spiel für die
playstation 4 und ein interessent
schreibt dem verkäufer hey ich kaufe das
spiel für zehn euro wenn du nicht
einverstanden bist gibt innerhalb von
zehn minuten bescheid ok nehme ist dann
für zehn euro wo kann ich abholen das
540 euro möchte ich gerne dafür das
hättest du vorhin machen können hätte
das ja ein zeitlimit jetzt hast du
automatisch zugestimmt wie bitte das ist
lächerlich ist gute taktik muss ich
sagen er allerdings direkt zum nächsten
bfm eine liebevoll und zwar verkauft
jemand diese brille denkt man im ersten
moment ist allerdings nicht ganz der
fall denn er schreibt in den titel suche
dieser chupa chups brille und da muss
ich mal ganz kurz sagen leute in irgend
jemand von euch diese super jobs brille
irgendwo zu hause rum fliegen hat bitte
schicken foto bei instagram ist alisa
luca sendet mir die zu ich will diese
brille haben hier verschenkt jemand eine
whatsapp kurtz gruppe gelauscht gerne
einem kernigen kurz und bringst deine
mitmenschen mit einem 14 gerne zum
kichern dann bist du hier genau richtig
schreibt mir eine nummer und sei dabei
von
[Musik]
ich würde rein kommen zum rewe am
hasselter platz kommen hallo das ist
schön welche adresse viele grüße
hasselter platz detmold rewe sie wohnen
also im rewe welche uhrzeit ja ich wohne
im tiefkühlregal dann passt es ihm
ganz gut spieltag eine frage wenn ihr
was auf ebay kleinanzeigen.de welche
random leute verkaufen würde die ihr
nicht kennt und nicht weiß was das für
gespalten sind würdet ihr euch bei denen
mit euch zu hause bei euch treffen
ich glaube ich auch nicht
beispiel auch sagen hier kommen
seit jahren haben wir eine eigene
hier verkauft jemand einen hagebaumarkt
anhänger hat sich allerdings mal wieder
bei den produkten verschrieben und
schreibt an mengen gab
ich frag mich echt gar nix mehr schönen
guten tag ist der schrott noch zu haben
würde das alles auf einmal abholen ich
habe einen großen ich habe auch einen
großen okay
okay
ich liebe sind stumpf um humor hier
verschenkt jemand ca 1 quadratmeter
natursteinpflaster und ein interessent
schreibt ein verkäufer ist diese artikel
noch verfügbar hallo leider werden sie
voraussichtlich heute abend abgeholt tut
mir leid vom wem werde ich abgeholt ich
kenne das gar nicht die steine werden
abgeholt
[Musik]
die sonne scheint es leider genau mit
dem box tut mir so leid hier schreibt
jemand ein zweites standbein gerade in
diesen zeiten ist wichtig aus diesem
grund renoviere ich jetzt bda ich bin
handwerklich ziemlich geschickt ich
freue mich auf eure aufträge und das
hier ist sein
beweisfoto also die fliesen sind auf
jeden fall perfekt symmetrisch
angebracht bruder haben hier verkauft
den mann vier ikea packs türen für 236
cm schränke und ein interessent fragt
ihn hallo ich hätte interesse an den
tischen türen sind diese noch verfügbar
sind die türen weiß oder eierschalen
farben denke er weiß und schickt foto
gegen die weiße tür hält
besonders heiße musst du erstmal kommen
guten abend sind die schienbeinschoner
mit dem spann schutz noch verfügbar
liebe grüße ja ja das sind sie kannst du
sie in schönebeck abholen liebe grüße
barbara schreibt sie um 7 uhr drei
stunden später antwortet dann der
interessent wieder schreibt ja
da muss ich hin daraufhin war nicht
jemand schon allerdings verkauft
unterschreibt aber auch indem sie sagt
sorry jetzt habe ich sie schon jemand
anderem versprochen ich hoffe er klaut
sie die ich hoffe jemand tritt hier
gegen deine ungeschützten schieben
wollte
[Musik]
kommen wir nun allerdings auch schon zu
den letzten beiden die befehls fürs
heutige video und zwar sind das wieder
rein
das habe ich ja oft so dass bei den
enden der webwelt videos in kanada noch
mal kommt und zwar erstarrten direkt mit
dem ersten mein fell ist flauschig ich
habe einen kleinen mund hallo ich bin's
1 zuckersüßer hund
ja
machen wir direkt weiter mit dem
nächsten und zwar rose sind rot das kind
es pennt und zwar im baby käfig
eigentlich keine ahnung wie man das
nennt
[Musik]
ich weiß es tut mir leid dass das tumor
level heute unterm erdkern ist an der
stelle mich dass heute ich wieder das
allerdings auf beenden meiner liebe
freunde ich hoffe es hat euch trotz
meiner vermeldeten ausstrahlung und bei
einer kaputten stimme und den komischen
hält heute auch irgendwie vielleicht
auch ein bisschen gefallen ist das getan
hat er das gern einen daumen hoch unter
dem video hier da abonniert main kanal
und klickt auf die glocke wenn die neue
videos nicht verpassen wollt ich musste
dieses video hier gerade so früh und
meiner montur hier aufnehmen weil ich
jetzt gleich nach köln fahren
also wenn ihr sehen wollt was bei mir so
die nächsten tage ab geht ich bin zum
beispiel auch bei einem champions league
spiel dann folgt auf instagram checke
meine stories aus und wir sehen uns
übermorgen bei dem neuen jahr wieder
[Musik]